On a Thursday morning in August, 2015, a staffer at a big hospital in downtown Houston, St. Joseph Medical Center, heard a Code Green on the intercom and did what they always did-- ran over to the room. Then it was a Code Blue. Code Blue means somebody needs immediate medical attention. Same room.
2015年8月一个周四的早上，休斯顿市中心圣约瑟夫医学中心的一名员工在对讲机里听到了“绿色警报”，于是做了他们平时总会做的事——跑向那个房间。接着响起了“蓝色警报”。蓝色警报意味着有人需要立即接受医疗救治。在同一个房间。
And I just see blood everywhere, all over the floor. I was actually shocked. It was just kind of smeared here. There was some there. But it was all over the floor. We had to put on-- we put shoe covers on in order to walk in the room. That was just how much it was.
我看到到处都是血，满地都是。我当时真的惊呆了。血就这么糊在那儿。那儿也有一些。但到处都是。我们不得不穿上鞋套才能走进那个房间。血量大到这种程度。
They walked in and saw a 26-year-old college student on the floor, handcuffed, with a bullet wound in his chest. He'd been tasered by police before he was shot.
他们走进去，看到一名26岁的大学生躺在地上，戴着手铐，胸部有枪伤。他在被枪击前曾被警察用泰瑟枪电击过。
And he still had the taser things attached to his chest. And I mean, that was the first time I'd ever seen what taser lines look like-- just a bunch of wires coming from him. And I remember the surgeon screaming at the cop to take his handcuffs off. He was like, "take the cuffs off now. We have no time to waste." And he said it multiple times. "Really? He's cuffed on the floor? We can't do anything with him cuffed. Just take the damn cuffs off him."
他的胸口还挂着泰瑟枪的电极。我是说，那是我第一次看到泰瑟枪的电线是什么样子——就是一堆连在他身上的线。我还记得外科医生对着警察大喊，让他把手铐解开。他说：“现在就把手铐解开。我们没时间浪费了。”他说了好几遍。“真的吗？他被拷在地上？他戴着手铐我们什么都做不了。快把那该死的手铐给他解开。”
Police had shot an unarmed patient in his own hospital room. The fallout from this incident was enormous. Federal investigators came in. The hospital's funding was threatened. It was so contentious that I recorded an interview with this hospital staffer, and to protect their identity, we have replaced the person's voice with an actor saying the exact same words. The story I'm about to tell you is one that we put together in collaboration with The New York Times, last year. The actor, by the way, is named Scott Shepherd.
警察在病房里枪击了一名手无寸铁的病人。这件事引发了巨大的影响。联邦调查人员介入了。医院的资金受到了威胁。这件事争议很大，我录制了对这名医院员工的采访，为了保护他们的身份，我们用演员的声音替换了当事人的声音，但内容一字不差。我接下来要讲的故事，是我们去年与《纽约时报》合作完成的。顺便提一下，这位演员叫斯科特·谢泼德。
To explain what happened in that hospital room, I want to back up to the day before, 20 hours before the shooting, and tell you about the patient. The doctor saved his life. His name is Alan Pean. He's alive and talking about what happened.
为了解释病房里发生的事，我想回溯到前一天，也就是枪击案发生前20小时，向你们介绍一下这位病人。医生挽救了他的生命。他的名字叫艾伦·皮恩。他还活着，并讲述了当时发生的事。
And when he does, before you get to the very interesting story about how he ended up with a bullet in his chest, it's also incredibly interesting to hear him describe the day that led up to the shooting, because during that day, over the course of just a few hours, basically his mind slipped away from him. Bit by bit, he stopped understanding what was real and what wasn't real. And he describes what that feels like in this way I have never heard anybody describe before.
当他讲述时，在你听到关于他胸部如何中枪的有趣故事之前，听他描述枪击案发生前的那一天也同样引人入胜，因为在那一天，在短短几个小时内，他的神志基本上离他而去。一点一点地，他不再能分清什么是真实的，什么是虚幻的。他用一种我从未听过的方式描述了那种感觉。
It's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "My Damn Mind." We have two stories on our program today-- in one, the brain working for you, and the other, this story, the brain very much not working for you, not being a helper, not being a pal. And let's get right to it.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“我该死的大脑”。我们今天有两个故事——一个讲述大脑为你工作，另一个，也就是这个故事，讲述大脑非常不为你工作，不是助手，也不是朋友。我们直接开始吧。
This is Act One, "When Your Hospital-Borne Infection is a Bullet." The week before this happened, Alan Pean was starting his last semester at college, in a new school in a new city. He'd just moved to Houston two weeks before, anxious to do well.
这是第一幕，“当你的院内感染是一颗子弹”。这件事发生前的一周，艾伦·皮恩刚开始大学的最后一个学期，在新的城市和新的学校。他两周前才搬到休斯顿，急于取得好成绩。
Alan comes from a family with a lot of doctors-- his dad, his uncle. Both his brothers are on their way to becoming doctors. In this family of overachievers, Alan's the one who's still figuring out what he wants to do. He plays video games with a group of friends from high school, smokes weed, soft-spoken, thoughtful, considerate.
艾伦出生于一个医生世家——他的父亲、叔叔。他的两个兄弟也都在成为医生的路上。在这个充满优等生的家庭里，艾伦是那个还在摸索自己想做什么的人。他会和高中好友一起打电子游戏，抽大麻，言语轻柔，深思熟虑，体贴入微。
And he moved to Houston with a plan to get things done-- finish school, get to grad school. He stopped smoking weed, time to buckle down. And he was stressed out, sleeping only four hours a night. But at the same time, he had all this energy, which I guess is something that just happens to him sometimes.
他带着目标搬到休斯顿——完成学业，读研究生。他戒掉了大麻，是时候努力了。他感到压力很大，每晚只睡四个小时。但与此同时，他浑身充满精力，我想这有时就是会发生在他身上的事。
I recognize it as a mania. OK, Alan. You're manic right now. But I didn't think much of it. I was like, OK, this is just going to happen for a little bit, and it'll go away.
我将其识别为躁狂发作。好吧，艾伦。你现在处于躁狂状态。但我没多想。我心想，好吧，这只会持续一会儿，它会过去的。
And that's because in the past, sometimes this would happen for a couple of days, and then it would go away.
那是因为在过去，这种情况有时会持续几天，然后就会消失。
And it would go away. Exactly.
而且它确实会消失。没错。
So he's trying to hold it together. He's going to class. He's forcing himself to talk to people at this new school. He's making himself do all the things that he's supposed to do.
所以他试图保持状态。他去上课。他强迫自己与这所新学校的人交谈。他强迫自己去做所有他应该做的事。
And it's working. On August 26, the day before the shooting, in his philosophy of science class, lots of people want to be in his study group. And when class ended, they made a plan to meet over the weekend.
而且奏效了。8月26日，枪击案发生的前一天，在他的科学哲学课上，很多人想加入他的学习小组。课结束后，他们计划周末见面。
And everyone was exchanging emails. And I was like, "all right, OK. So I'll see you guys later." And you know, it's like, we were in the quad, and I'm walking out to go to my car. And I just continue walking. I feel great. This is good. I finally have my group ready to go. I'm going to go ahead and get home and continue being productive. I have a book that I really like to read. I'm going to go finish that. And then--
大家都在交换电子邮件。我就说：“好吧，那我们待会儿见。”你知道，当时我们在方庭，我正走去开车。我继续走着。我感觉很棒。这很好。我终于组建好我的团队了。我要回家继续保持高产。我有一本很喜欢的书。我要把它读完。然后——
This is the moment that we're roughly 20 hours before the shooting in the hospital room. When Alan gets in the car, he starts thinking about all the things that he needs to read and do and study, and something in him just kind of tips, he says.
这就是距离病房枪击案大约20小时的时刻。当艾伦上车时，他开始想到所有需要阅读、处理和研究的事情，他说，他内心的某种东西崩溃了。
He starts to panic. But you know, he gets home, he starts to cook some food, he tries to calm down. He's got a plan to play a video game online with his buddies. He hooks up the PS4, gets on FaceTime with his friends.
他开始恐慌。但他回到家，开始做些食物，试图冷静下来。他计划和好友在线玩游戏。他接上PS4，和朋友进行FaceTime视频通话。
So I'm trying to play on the game, but it's like my wires start getting crossed. Things start getting confusing. Confusing like I have this controller, but then a thought would interject.
我试图玩游戏，但就像我的线路短路了一样。事情开始变得混乱。混乱到我手里拿着手柄，但有一个念头会插进来。
He thought this controller somehow switches on a processor inside of him.
他认为这个手柄以某种方式启动了他体内的处理器。
Like I'm this bionic being who had been reprogrammed by the enemy. It's like where you have the delusional thoughts competing with your rational thoughts. And then you disproving your delusional thoughts, but then another one comes up. And it seems more likely.
就像我是一个被敌人重新编程的仿生人。就像妄想思维与理性思维在竞争。你反驳了妄想思维，但另一个又出现了。而且它看起来更真实。
His computer, he thought, was not his computer. It was a state-of-the-art device that could summon drones to destroy his apartment complex. Meaningless coincidences seemed like signals that he was on a secret mission.
他认为他的电脑不是电脑。而是一台尖端设备，可以召唤无人机摧毁他的公寓大楼。毫无意义的巧合似乎成了他在执行秘密任务的信号。
Now, Alan had had delusional episodes before-- two times. The first was in 2008, when he was a freshman at the University of Texas at Austin. It lasted about a week.
艾伦之前有过妄想症发作——两次。第一次是在2008年，他在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校读大一的时候。持续了大约一周。
Where I thought that I was President Barack Obama. That I was either a lookalike or someone that could be used as a replacement. But it's not so much like--
当时我以为我是巴拉克·奥巴马总统。要么我长得像他，要么我是可以被当作替身的人。但这并不是说——
I should tell you that you're a light-skinned black man with short hair. You look nothing like President Barack Obama.
我得告诉你，你是一个皮肤白皙、头发短的黑人男性。你看起来一点也不像巴拉克·奥巴马总统。
Yeah. So--
是的。所以——
The next summer, it happened again. And it was more of a biblical-type deal this time, Alan says, a delusion with demons in disguise, and he was on the verge of being sent to hell. Alan was briefly hospitalized, diagnosed as possible bipolar and put on anti-psychotic medications for a while.
第二年夏天，它又发生了。艾伦说，这次更像是一个圣经类型的事情，一种伪装成恶魔的妄想，他处于被打入地狱的边缘。艾伦曾短暂住院，被诊断为双相情感障碍，并服用了一段时间的抗精神病药物。
And he recovered. Six years passed without another incident. But that night, on the PS4 with his friends on FaceTime, it was all kicking in again.
然后他康复了。六年过去了，没有再发生事故。但那天晚上，在PS4上和朋友FaceTime时，一切又开始了。
And what are your friends seeing? Do they know you're going through this freak-out?
你朋友们看到了什么？他们知道你正在经历这种崩溃吗？
They start asking, Alan, what's wrong? They had realized that I was acting strange. Like, why can't he log on to the computer? Why can't he log on to the PS4 or whatever? Why can't he do that?
他们开始问，艾伦，你怎么了？他们意识到我的行为很奇怪。比如，为什么他不能登录电脑？为什么他不能登录PS4什么的？为什么他做不到？
Oh, because you're unable to do it?
哦，因为你做不到？
Yeah. I was like, no. I shouldn't do it, because if I do, they'll triangulate on my position.
是的。我当时心想，不。我不应该这么做，因为如果我做了，他们就会确定我的位置。
But you didn't say that to your friends?
但你没跟朋友说这些？
I couldn't tell it to them because I didn't know who exactly they were.
我没法告诉他们，因为我不知道他们到底是谁。
So he gets off the FaceTime call. It's now 13 hours before the shooting.
于是他挂断了FaceTime电话。现在距离枪击案还有13小时。
And I was like, who can I trust? Well, obviously, you trust your brother, your unit, right? So he's my little brother, Dominique. And I call him and I tell him, "hey, man, I'm having a panic attack. I'm having a panic attack. And I don't know what to do. And I think it's getting worse than that."
我心想，我能信任谁？好吧，显然，你信任你的兄弟，你的血亲，对吧？所以他是我的弟弟，多米尼克。我给他打电话，我说：“嘿，兄弟，我正在经历恐慌发作。我正在恐慌发作。我不知道该怎么办。而且我觉得情况比那更糟。”
So he called me at 10:00 PM. I had just got back from class.
所以他在晚上10点给我打了电话。我刚从课上回来。
Dominique says, actually, there's a fair amount of "how was your day" kind of small talk with Alan taking these weird, deep, deep breaths before Alan actually admitted he was having a panic attack.
多米尼克说，实际上，在艾伦承认他正在恐慌发作之前，他们聊了一些“你今天过得怎么样”之类的闲话，期间艾伦会有那种奇怪的、深深的呼吸。
And I was like, "oh, OK." Well, I get anxious kind of often, too. So I walked him through some just relaxation exercises. So I was like, take a deep breath-- in, out. Lie on your back. Put some water on your face.
我说：“哦，好吧。”嗯，我也经常感到焦虑。所以我引导他做了一些放松练习。我对他说，深呼吸——吸气，呼气。平躺。往脸上泼点水。
Water on your face? Like cold water?
往脸上泼水？像冷水那样？
Yeah. Cold water on your face.
是的。往脸上泼冷水。
And he was like, "oh, OK. Well, put some cold water on your face. Cold water on your face." And I was like, "what?" And I'm like-- I actually go to say-- I'm, like, "is it because I'm overheating?"
他说：“哦，好的。好吧，往脸上泼冷水。往脸上泼冷水。”我心想，“什么？”我实际上想说——我心想，“是因为我过热了吗？”
Like you're some sort of robot?
就像你是某种机器人？
Right. And he might also know that. And he knows what I need to do in order for my circuits to calm down. [SIGH]
对。而且他可能也知道这一点。他知道为了让我的电路冷静下来，我需要做什么。[叹气]
It continues like this. The part of Alan's brain that looks at the world and draws conclusions about what he sees doesn't stop doing that. It's like he's still in there, thinking and applying logic. It just keeps arriving at the wrong answers. So innocent statements said to him, like "I don't know anybody in Houston who can come over to your apartment," Alan inserts into the delusion.
事情就是这样持续下去。艾伦大脑中观察世界并对其所得结论进行判断的部分并没有停止工作。就像他依然在里面，思考并应用逻辑。只是它总是在得出错误的答案。所以对他说出的无辜陈述，比如“我不认识休斯顿有人能到你的公寓来”，艾伦都会将其植入妄想中。
I took that as code. There's no agents in your area that could come to your assistance. Then I'm thinking, like, well, wait a minute. Like, what if-- what if he's not really my brother? It could be some sort of trap.
我把它当作暗号。你们区域没有特工能来支援。然后我心想，等等。万一——万一他不是我兄弟呢？这可能是某种陷阱。
Alan hangs up on his brother. Dominique gets their dad to reach out. Here he is.
艾伦挂断了他兄弟的电话。多米尼克找他们的父亲介入。这就是他。
So I call him, and I try to calm him through it on the phone to try to relax him.
所以我给他打电话，试图在电话里安抚他，让他放松下来。
This is Alan's dad, Dr. Harold Pean. He's originally from Haiti, hence the accent.
这是艾伦的父亲，哈罗德·皮恩医生。他原籍海地，所以有口音。
I ask him, "Alan, how you doing? You're having some problem, they're telling me," and try to relax him to get his mind off. But he was very anxious. He was not able to focus, to control it. And then suddenly, he say, "well, I think I'm going to just go drive to the hospital or something."
我问他：“艾伦，你好吗？他们告诉我你遇到了一些问题，”试图让他放松，转移注意力。但他非常焦虑。他无法集中精神，无法控制。然后他突然说：“好吧，我想我还是开车去医院什么的吧。”
Alan doesn't tell his dad or his brother that he's having delusions. He doesn't say what he's really thinking, which is that he's in greater and greater danger if he stays at his apartment, that there are snipers outside watching the front of the building, that if he walks out his front door he'll get shot, and they're moving in.
艾伦没有告诉父亲或兄弟他正在遭受妄想。他没有说他内心真实的想法，即如果他留在公寓里，他会处于越来越大的危险中；窗外有狙击手监视着楼前；如果他走出前门，他会被枪杀，他们正在逼近。
I thought at that point that time elapsed too long and that they're closing in on my position, and they're going to be there any moment. So I'm talking with my dad, and I call him Pop. So I'm like, Pop-- and then the following word in my mind was pop, which made me believe that the phone was going to explode, right? And then I run out, throw my phone into the toilet, and run out into the balcony and close the balcony door behind me.
当时我觉得时间拖得太久了，他们正在包围我的位置，随时都会到。所以我正和我父亲谈话，我叫他“老爸”。所以我心想，老爸——然后我脑海中接下来的词是“砰”（pop），这让我相信电话会爆炸，对吧？然后我跑出去，把手机扔进马桶，跑到阳台上，关上阳台门。
So I'm on the balcony. It's the third-story balcony. And I'm like, OK, well, just remember your training. And I start to climb over on the other side and essentially let go and catch myself again on the second balcony area. And--
所以我在阳台上。这是三楼的阳台。我心想，好吧，记住你的训练。我开始爬到另一边，基本上松手，然后又抓住了二楼的阳台区域。然后——
What?
什么？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm just trying to picture this. So you're in a suburban apartment complex. You're on the third floor. You're on a balcony. You're holding on to it. You let go. And you're able to drop one floor down and catch--
我只是在尝试想象这个画面。所以你在一个郊区的公寓大楼里。你在三楼。你在阳台上。你抓着它。你松手了。你能往下掉一层楼并抓住——
Catch myself.
抓住自己。
And not break your arms?
而且没摔断胳膊？
Nothing happened. Yeah. All my muscles must have been-- you're like high. You're just-- adrenaline pumping. That's what I'm trying to say, like an adrenaline high, and it's just--
什么事都没发生。是的。我所有的肌肉一定都——就像你在亢奋中。你只是——肾上腺素飙升。这就是我想说的，就像肾上腺素带来的快感，它只是——
OK, then?
好吧，然后呢？
So then after that, I catch myself on the second story. And I look down. And I keep telling myself, just remember your training. You trained for this.
在那之后，我抓住了二楼。我往下看。我一直告诉自己，记住你的训练。你为此训练过。
And that refers to nothing, right?
那指的不是什么吧，对吗？
What, my football training? No, I don't know. I never trained for anything. So I'm just here, like, remember your training. You know, so--
什么，我的足球训练？不，我不知道。我从来没接受过任何训练。所以我只是在那儿，心想，记住你的训练。你知道，所以——
Yeah.
是的。
And I look down, and there's these two AC units down there. And I basically, from the second story to the AC units, I do a parkour stunt, like jump off of it and then jump onto the sidewalk. And I start running.
我往下看，下面有两台空调外机。我基本上从二楼跳到空调外机上，做了一个跑酷特技，像跳下去然后跳到人行道上。然后我开始跑。
OK, I know it's a cliche, but the mind, it is powerful. By the way, this story about jumping down the balcony seems to be completely true. We checked with the property manager of the building. And for a bunch of reasons that I won't bore you with here, the way Alan's apartment was locked, the only way he could have gotten out was off the balcony.
好吧，我知道这是老生常谈，但思维，它确实强大。顺便说一句，这个关于跳下阳台的故事似乎完全是真的。我们和楼管核实过了。出于一些我不会在这里让你感到无聊的原因，艾伦公寓的锁法导致他唯一的出路就是阳台。
So after Alan action-heroes his way down the balcony, he makes his way to his car-- not a direct path, of course. Too dangerous. Evasive maneuvers, under cover of night. He believes that he called in a drone strike using Google Maps, and any second the whole apartment complex is going to be blown up. So he's racing against the clock.
所以艾伦像动作英雄一样从阳台下来后，他朝自己的车走去——当然不是直接走过去。太危险了。采取规避机动，在夜色的掩护下。他相信他利用谷歌地图呼叫了无人机空袭，随时整栋公寓大楼都要被炸平。所以他在与时间赛跑。
And it's interesting. I didn't know what I thought a delusion would be like. I thought it might be like a hallucination or something. It might make no sense when you look at it later. But in this case, it's a totally logical story with consistent details, like a movie or a video game.
这很有趣。我不知道我以为妄想会是什么样子。我以为可能就像幻觉什么的。当你事后看它时，它可能毫无意义。但在这种情况下，它是一个完全合乎逻辑的故事，细节前后一致，就像电影或电子游戏一样。
I'm kind of jogging, running.
我当时大概在慢跑、奔跑。
And you're full-on delusion? You're not ever coming to--
你完全处于妄想中？你从来没有清醒过来——
Yeah. At this point, I do believe I'm a bionic person. I'm a cyborg. I'm a secret agent on a mission to break himself out from behind enemy lines. So I get in my car, and I basically peel out. And I get to the gate.
是的。此时，我确实相信我是一个仿生人。我是半机械人。我是执行秘密任务的特工，要从敌后冲出来。所以我上了车，基本上猛冲出去。我到了大门口。
The gate of your suburban apartment--
你郊区公寓的门——
Apartment complex. And I'm like, why isn't the gate opening? They locked it. They locked it, of course. You know, so I just rammed the gate open.
公寓大楼。我心想，为什么门不开？他们锁上了。当然，他们锁上了。你知道，所以我直接把门撞开了。
You rammed the gate with your car?
你开车撞了门？
That's right. Boom, it opens. Get out. Take a left, and there I am. I'm driving. I'm driving, and I'm having these thoughts, like, that place is about to explode.
没错。轰，门开了。出去。左转，我就在那里。我在开车。我开着车，脑子里有这些想法，比如，那个地方马上要爆炸了。
However, as I'm driving, I tell myself, you were supposed to go somewhere before. Where's the rendezvous point? And it's at the hospital. It's at the hospital that you're supposed to go to. That's where the good guys are.
然而，开车时，我告诉自己，你本来是要去别的地方的。集合点在哪里？是在医院。你要去的是医院。好人都在那里。
But then he has a moment. He remembered, he and his dad had talked about going to the hospital for a different reason.
但随后他有了一瞬间的清醒。他记得他和父亲谈过因为别的原因去医院。
I had a moment of clarity. I need my medication. I need that. It's like-- it's Geodon. It's an anti-psychotic.
我有了一瞬间的清醒。我需要我的药。我需要那个。它就像——是Geodon。它是一种抗精神病药。
Then the delusion kicks back in. So he's driving, looking for a hospital. Remember, he's just moved to town that month. And he sees St. Joseph Medical Center, Houston's oldest hospital, and the only one downtown.
然后妄想再次占了上风。所以他在开车，寻找医院。记住，他那个月刚搬到城里。他看到了圣约瑟夫医学中心，休斯顿最古老的医院，也是市中心唯一的医院。
It's like I just lost control of the car. I don't really remember-- for me, it was like I was in the car, and the next thing I know, the car has crashed, and I'm falling out.
就像我失去了对车的控制。我真的不记得——对我来说，感觉就像我在车里，接下来我知道的就是，车撞了，我从车里跌了出来。
That's it? That's all you remember of the accident?
就是这样？关于事故你只记得这些？
Yeah.
是的。
How badly damaged was your car?
你的车损坏得有多严重？
The car was totaled.
车报废了。
The car was totaled?
车报废了？
Totaled.
报废了。
You just rammed into--
你只是撞到了——
The side of a wall.
一面墙的侧面。
He had actually hit a bunch of cars before he slammed into the side of the hospital at high speed. The front of the car caved in, airbags inflated. Even in his psychotic state, Alan wore a seat belt.
他在高速撞向医院侧面之前，实际上已经撞了好几辆车。车头塌陷，气囊弹出。即使在精神错乱的状态下，艾伦还是系了安全带。
I mean, I'm religious. I thank God that I didn't hurt anyone else there. I thank God that people there just miraculously did not get hit at all.
我是说，我有宗教信仰。我感谢上帝我没有伤害到那里的人。我感谢上帝，那里的人奇迹般地完全没有被撞到。
So you get out of the car. You walk to the hospital, which is how far from you?
所以你下了车。你走到医院，离你有多远？
10 feet. I'm at the hospital. I crashed into the hospital. And there's an EMT guy right there.
10英尺。我在医院。我撞进了医院。那里正好有个急救人员。
The EMT sees that Alan just crashed his car and probably needs medical attention. They put Alan on a stretcher, take him into the ER.
急救人员看到艾伦刚撞了车，可能需要医疗救治。他们把艾伦放在担架上，送进了急诊室。
This is where this turns from one kind of story, a story of Alan losing control of his mind, to the other story we're telling here, of how you can show up in an emergency room needing psychiatric help and end up shot by the police in the hospital. And from this point in the story, for the 11 hours before the shooting, we don't have to rely on Alan's recollection. There's documentation of what he looked like from the outside to people who were not in his head, people who did not think that he was a robot cyborg on a secret mission.
这正是故事从一种类型——艾伦失去理智的故事，转变为我们在这里讲述的另一种故事的地方：你如何能因为需要精神病学帮助而出现在急诊室，最终却被医院里的警察枪击。从故事的这一点，即枪击案发生前11小时，我们不必依赖艾伦的回忆。有书面记录显示，从那些不在他脑子里、不认为他是执行秘密任务的机器人半机械人的眼中，他看起来是什么样子的。
We have Alan's medical records. He gave permission for the hospital to turn them over. And there's a 50-page report, prepared by federal investigators, of what happened from the time Alan arrived at the hospital until he was shot.
我们有艾伦的医疗记录。他授权医院将记录移交。联邦调查人员准备了一份50页的报告，记录了从艾伦到达医院到他被枪击期间发生的事情。
Alan gets to the emergency room at 10 minutes before midnight. And St. Joseph is a big downtown hospital. It gets lots of trauma patients, lots of mentally ill patients, some homeless people. Staff often have to quickly assess what a patient needs to be treated for.
艾伦在午夜前10分钟到达急诊室。圣约瑟夫是一家大型市中心医院。它接收很多创伤病人、很多精神病患者，还有一些无家可归的人。员工通常必须迅速评估病人需要治疗什么。
And even though the staff notices all kinds of things that might lead them to treat Alan for his psychiatric problem, they don't do it. What they treat Alan for is the car crash, which must have seemed pretty urgent. The diagnosis in his medical chart is hand abrasion, substance abuse, motor vehicle accident.
尽管工作人员注意到了各种可能导致他们治疗艾伦精神问题的迹象，但他们并没有这样做。他们治疗艾伦的是车祸，这看起来肯定非常紧急。他病历上的诊断是手部擦伤、物质滥用、机动车事故。
They do a CT scan of his head, spine, chest, abdomen, and pelvis, looking for injuries. They test him for drugs and alcohol. Those come up negative, except for marijuana, which can linger in the body for weeks. Alan says that he tried to tell the ER staff what it is that he came for, that he was having a manic episode.
他们对他进行了头部、脊柱、胸部、腹部和骨盆的CT扫描，寻找损伤。他们对他进行了药物和酒精测试。测试结果呈阴性，除了大麻，大麻可以在体内残留数周。艾伦说他试图告诉急诊室工作人员他为什么而来，他正在经历躁狂发作。
It's like I snapped back into myself. I just say, "I'm manic, I'm manic, I'm manic." And I say it multiple times. And I'm saying that. And there's people around me. There's nurses and stuff who are putting needles and things into me. And it never clicked.
就像我恢复了清醒。我只是说，“我躁狂，我躁狂，我躁狂。”我说了好几次。我当时就在说。我周围有人。有护士之类的，在给我打针。但他们从未听进去。
There's no mention of that in his medical records. And there's no mention of phone calls that his brother Christian and his father say they made at 1:00 AM and 1:14 AM, respectively, to alert the hospital about Alan's psychiatric issues-- though that's not unusual that phone calls like that wouldn't be mentioned in the chart.
他的医疗记录中没有提到这一点。而且没有提到他的兄弟克里斯蒂安和父亲分别在凌晨1点和1点14分打的那些电话，试图提醒医院艾伦的精神问题——尽管这种电话没有在病历中提到并不罕见。
But the medical records do include all kinds of things that could have tipped the staff off about what was really wrong. On Alan's arrival at the ER, the first handwritten notes from a resident on duty include that Alan is someone who has manic depression. Then Alan is so incoherent, making so little sense, that the attending physician notes in the chart that he can't get Alan to describe his medical history or even a basic rundown of his symptoms. By 1:30 in the morning, the nurses' notes say that Alan is acting weirdly, trying to pull out his IVs and his lines. They, quote, "educate him on his behavior and ask him not to remove any equipment."
但医疗记录确实包括了各种可能提醒工作人员他真正出了什么问题的迹象。在艾伦到达急诊室时，当班住院医师的第一份手写记录包括艾伦是一个有躁狂抑郁症的人。然后艾伦语无伦次，逻辑不通，以至于主治医师在图表中记录，他无法让艾伦描述他的病史，甚至无法进行基本的症状总结。到了凌晨1点半，护士的记录显示艾伦表现得很奇怪，试图拔掉他的静脉注射管和导线。她们“教育了他关于他的行为，并要求他不要移除任何设备”。
He doesn't stop. He tries to pull out his own catheter. This continues for hours. He starts telling the staff that he feels all better, no need for any equipment.
他没有停止。他试图拔掉自己的导尿管。这种情况持续了数小时。他开始告诉工作人员他感觉好多了，不需要任何设备。
But they still don't treat him like a psychiatric case. Alan and his family told me, their sense of the staff's attitude was, this is just a guy, drunk or on drugs, crashed his car. Happens all the time. Alan's put into a hospital room for observation of his injuries. His father booked a plane to Houston from their home in McAllen, Texas.
但他们仍然没有把他当作精神病病例对待。艾伦和他的家人告诉我，他们对工作人员态度的感觉是：这只是个喝醉或吸毒的人，撞了车。这种情况常有。艾伦被送入观察病房观察伤势。他父亲预订了一张从他们家所在的德克萨斯州麦卡伦飞往休斯顿的机票。
We decide to fly right away, yeah, 6:45. We went to Houston at 6:45 in the morning.
我们决定马上飞过去，是的，6:45。我们早上6:45去了休斯顿。
Dr. Pean and his wife, Paloma, get to Alan's hospital room around 10:00 AM.
皮恩医生和他的妻子帕洛玛在早上10点左右到达艾伦的病房。
Well, I say, "Alan, we are here. You know, we've come to see you." He say, "hi, Pop." But he would not-- I say, "how you doing?" He would not tell me anything. And he was different than usual. So I say, well, that's not him.
嗯，我说，“艾伦，我们到了。你知道，我们来看你了。”他说，“嗨，老爸。”但他不会——我说，“你感觉怎么样？”他什么也不肯告诉我不。他和平常不一样。所以我说，好吧，那不是他。
He's totally withdrawn. Didn't hug them hello. Alan explains why.
他完全退缩了。没有拥抱他们表示问候。艾伦解释了原因。
I do recall my parents showing up. And I don't actually believe it's them. I don't think it's them.
我确实记得我父母出现了。但我实际上不相信那是他们。我不认为那是他们。
In Alan's mind, he's still on his mission, which is evolving. The TV in his room is sending coded messages. And the IV tubes he's hooked up to?
在艾伦的脑海里，他仍在执行他的任务，而任务在演变。病房里的电视在发送编码信息。他接上的静脉导管？
They're putting the serum that I needed in order for the morphing process to begin, to morph, to look more like Barack Obama. Because if he is taken out, they don't know where he is. But they need someone to speak out as though the government is still functioning as normal.
它们正在输入我开始变形过程所需的血清，去变形，看起来更像巴拉克·奥巴马。因为如果他被除掉了，他们不知道他在哪。但他们需要有人以政府依然正常运转的姿态发言。
Now his dad knows none of that. All he knows is something is wrong. He goes to the nurses' station.
他父亲对这一切一无所知。他只知道出了问题。他去了护士站。
So I talk with the nurse, and I told them, look, I think he's having some kind of anxiety or panic, and I wanted to talk with the doctor. And I say to her that I think he may need some kind of psychiatric help.
所以我跟护士谈话，我告诉他们，看，我觉得他有某种焦虑或恐慌，我想跟医生谈谈。我告诉她我觉得他可能需要某种精神病学帮助。
Did you say, I want a psychiatric evaluation?
你说了“我想要精神病评估”吗？
That's right. I told her, I think he needs to be evaluated by a psychiatrist.
没错。我告诉她，我觉得他需要接受精神科医生的评估。
And what did the nurse say?
护士说了什么？
Oh, she just didn't pay attention to me. She said he's going to be discharged. That's all she said.
哦，她根本没理我。她说他马上就要出院了。这就是她说的全部。
According to the report by federal investigators, the nurse confirmed he did ask for a psychiatric evaluation, and she did tell him Alan was going to be discharged.
根据联邦调查人员的报告，护士证实他确实要求进行精神病评估，并且她确实告诉他艾伦要出院了。
And I asked what medication they were giving him. They said they were giving him cyclobenzaprine. And I told her, well, I don't think that's appropriate. Maybe that will make it worse.
我问他们给他开了什么药。他们说给他用了环苯扎林。我告诉她，嗯，我觉得那不合适。也许那会使情况更糟。
What was your fear that it would do to Alan?
你担心那会对艾伦做什么？
That's a muscle relaxant. But some people, it may cause psychosis, actually, because that's part of the side-effect-- confusion, dizziness, psychosis. I think it would probably make him more disoriented, confused. But she said, well, that's what the doctor prescribed.
那是一种肌肉松弛剂。但对有些人来说，它可能会导致精神错乱，因为这是副作用的一部分——精神混乱、头晕、精神错乱。我觉得它可能会让他更加迷失方向、困惑。但她说，好吧，那是医生开的药。
Did you identify yourself as a doctor?
你表明你是医生了吗？
Yeah. I told the nurse that I'm a physician from McAllen, internal medicine. But she just didn't pay attention. She thought maybe I was lying. I don't know what was in her head.
是的。我告诉护士我是来自麦卡伦的内科医生。但她根本没在意。她以为我可能在撒谎。我不知道她在想什么。
He said the nurse said to him-- maybe hearing his accent-- you might be a doctor somewhere, but you're not a doctor here. So Dr. Pean and his wife figured, OK, no help here. They would drive Alan back home to McAllen and get psychiatric help there. They left to arrange for a car rental.
他说护士对他说——也许听到他的口音——你可能是哪里的医生，但你不是这儿的医生。所以皮恩医生和他的妻子觉得，好吧，这里没帮助。他们会开车把艾伦带回麦卡伦，在那里寻求精神病学帮助。他们离开去安排租车事宜。
The doctor did come looking for them, according to federal investigators, but they'd already left. Alan gets shot in his own hospital room less than 40 minutes after they go. Here's how that goes down. I'm going to read you a little bit from the 50-page report issued by federal investigators.
根据联邦调查人员的说法，医生确实来找过他们，但他们已经离开了。他们在离开不到40分钟后，艾伦就在自己的病房里被枪击了。事情经过是这样的。我将为你朗读联邦调查人员发布的50页报告中的一小部分。
Quote, "At 11 o'clock, the patient was encouraged to put on his gown after he had a shower, but refused and started dancing in his room. The patient came out of his room naked four to five times. The nurse stated at this time, the patient was calmly responsive. She stated each time she redirected him, he would say, yes, ma'am. Radio. OK, ma'am. When asked what year it was, he said, 1989.
引用，“11点，病人在洗完澡后被鼓励穿上病号服，但他拒绝了，并开始在房间里跳舞。病人裸体走出房间四到五次。护士表示此时病人反应冷静。她表示每次她引导他回来，他都会说，是的，女士。明白。好的，女士。当被问到今年是哪一年，他说，1989年。”
Some time later, the patient came out in the hallway naked, except he had shoes on. He was told to go back to his room, and the nurse would come in to assist him with his gown. She stated she went to the room with another nurse and was trying to help the patient into his gown.
过了一段时间，病人裸体出现在走廊上，除了脚上穿着鞋。他被告知回到房间，护士会进去协助他穿上病号服。她表示她和另一名护士去了房间，正试图帮助病人穿上病号服。
They told him to turn around so they could tie the gown. The patient started to dance and would not comply. The nurse said the patient was acting inappropriately. She said he would not comply with her orders to turn around so his gown could be buttoned up."
她们告诉他转身以便系上病号服。病人开始跳舞，不肯配合。护士说病人表现不恰当。她说他不配合她转身穿上病号服的命令。”
Do you remember why you were going out into the hallway naked?
你还记得为什么你要裸体走到走廊上吗？
I don't remember-- I don't recall dancing, but I do know that I was going out there because whenever I finished taking my showers, well, where's the suit?
我不记得——我不记得跳舞，但我确实知道我走出去是因为每当我洗完澡，好吧，西装在哪儿？
Remember, he's morphing into Barack Obama. He's about to address the nation. You need a suit for that kind of thing. In the hallway--
记住，他正在变身为巴拉克·奥巴马。他即将向全国发表讲话。那种场合需要一套西装。在走廊里——
I'd expect other people to be there that would help me with the changing process, just to look professional or to hand me my script.
我会期待其他人也在那里帮助我完成变形过程，只是为了看起来职业一点，或者把讲稿递给我。
If the patient doesn't comply with orders, it's protocol in the hospital to ring for security. And the nurse does that. Now at this particular hospital, calling security usually gets you uniformed guards who don't carry weapons, but also might get you off-duty cops who are on the security team. It depends on who's available.
如果病人不配合命令，医院的规程是呼叫安保。护士照做了。而在这一家特定的医院，呼叫安保通常来的是不带武器的穿制服警卫，但也可能来的是安保团队里的休班警察。取决于谁有空。
This time, it's the cops who arrive, in full Houston Police Department uniforms with guns. They go into his room and close the door. This, by the way, is not standard hospital procedure, I was told. A nurse, a doctor, somebody treating the patient, should  have been in there with them.
这一次，来的是警察，身穿休斯顿警察局的制服，配有枪支。他们走进他的房间并关上了门。顺便说一下，有人告诉我，这不是标准的医院程序。一名护士、医生，或者任何正在治疗该病人的工作人员，应该和他们一起进去。
Now at this point, once the cops are inside that room, the story gets a little hazy. It's not totally clear what happened inside the room. Police turned down our interview request. And Alan's lawyers told him not to talk about the details either because the whole thing is going to court.
现在，一旦警察进了那个房间，故事就变得有点模糊了。房间里到底发生了什么并不完全清楚。警方拒绝了我们的采访请求。艾伦的律师也告诉他不要谈论细节，因为整件事都要上法庭。
But there are some things we know for sure. We know the cops were not in that room for long, a few minutes at most. We know there was a scuffle. Several people told investigators that. And the staffer I interviewed, whose voice we're replacing with an actor's, said you  could hear it from outside Alan's hospital room.
但有些事情我们是确定的。我们知道警察在那个房间里待的时间不长，最多几分钟。我们知道发生了扭打。几个人告诉调查人员这件事。我采访的那名员工——我们用演员的声音替换了他的——说你在艾伦病房外就能听到声音。
We heard noise. And we couldn't identify exactly what it was. We didn't know if it was maybe a table hitting a wall. it was just like a pop and all kinds of stuff.
我们听到了噪音。我们无法确定那到底是什么。我们不知道那是否可能是桌子撞到墙的声音。就像砰的一声，然后是各种东西。
One nurse told investigators she heard a scream. On the day of the shooting  in August, the Houston Police Department issued a brief statement about what happened next. It's still on their website.
一名护士告诉调查人员她听到了尖叫声。在8月份枪击案发生当天，休斯顿警察局就接下来的情况发表了一份简短的声明。它仍然在他们的网站上。
It says, when the officers arrived, Alan attacked. Quote, "The patient suddenly physically assaulted Officer Ortega, striking him in the head, causing a laceration. At that time, Officer Law deployed his  conducted  energy device--" that's the taser-- "which had no apparent effect on the suspect who continued to assault the officers. Officer Ortega, fearing for his and his partner's safety, then discharged his duty weapon, striking the subject one time."
声明称，当警察到达时，艾伦发动了攻击。引用，“病人突然对奥尔特加警官进行人身攻击，击中了他的头部，造成裂伤。当时，劳警官部署了他的警用导电装置——也就是泰瑟枪——这对嫌疑人没有产生明显的抑制作用，嫌疑人继续攻击警察。奥尔特加警官担心自己和搭档的安全，随后发射了配枪，击中嫌疑人一次。”
Alan disputes this account. He and his lawyers say he did not attack the officers first but they charged him first, and he responded.
艾伦对这个说法有异议。他和他的律师说他没有先攻击警察，而是他们先冲向他，他作出了反应。
Soon the door to his hospital room opened. That, by the way, is when the hospital staffer who I interviewed arrived in the hallway outside Alan's room. Again, we've replaced the staffer's voice with an actor saying the same words and-- I hope this isn't weird-- you're hearing my original questions from the recording of the original interview mixed with the actor's voice.
很快他病房的门开了。顺便说一下，那正是我采访的那名医院员工到达艾伦病房外走廊的时候。同样，我们用演员的声音替换了该员工的声音，说的是同样的话，而且——我希望这不奇怪——你听到的是录音中我原来的提问，混杂着演员的声音。
Apparently, they had probably just opened it. And the first thing I seen was a cop fall out of the room on the floor.
显然，他们可能刚打开门。我看到的第一件事是一个警察从房间里摔倒在地。
So you're out in the hallway.
所以你在走廊上。
Correct. Well, I didn't go that close to the room because when you see a cop with a bloody eye on the floor, that states, stay where you are. Don't go any closer.
没错。嗯，我没有靠房间太近，因为当你看到一个警察眼睛带血躺在地上时，那就意味着，待在你原来的地方。不要再靠近。
He was bleeding from his eye?
他在流血，眼睛吗？
His head. Like right above his right eye. We weren't sure if it was the eye or the head. It was just this huge, red, fresh gash. It was big.
他的头。就在右眼上方。我们不确定是眼睛还是头。就只是那个巨大的、红色的、新鲜的伤口。它很大。
This is from the account by the federal investigators. Quote, "Inside the room, the other officer was standing over the patient, who was lying on the floor. He had a taser on his upper chest. There was blood on the wall and floor. The patient was conscious, trying to get up, saying he was Super-Man and needed to get up.
这是来自联邦调查人员的报告。引用，“在房间里，另一名警察站在躺在地上的病人上方。他的上胸部有一把泰瑟枪。墙上和地板上有血。病人有意识，试图起身，说他是超人，需要起来。”
The doctor who rushed into the room and treated him told investigators--" again, I'm quoting the federal report here, quote-- "he  heard a Code Blue page overhead while he was walking upstairs. He realized it was his patient's room and went to the floor. He went to the patient's room and saw him lying on the floor on his back with a drape over him.
冲进房间并治疗他的医生告诉调查人员——再次引用联邦报告，引用——“他在走上楼时听到了头顶的蓝色警报广播。他意识到是病人的房间，并赶到了那一层。他去了病人的房间，看到他仰面躺在地上，身上盖着布。”
The patient was quiet. His eyes were closed. The doctor says he took the drape off the patient and saw he was handcuffed. When he asked what happened, he was told the patient was just tasered.
病人很安静。眼睛闭着。医生说他把病人身上的布拿开，看到他戴着手铐。当他问发生了什么时，得到的回答是病人刚被泰瑟枪电击。
He asked if the patient was shot, because of the blood and  multiple wounds. The response was that  the patient was tasered. When the doctor  began to assess the patient, somebody mentioned that he was shot."
他问病人是否中枪了，因为有血迹和多处伤口。得到的回答是病人被泰瑟枪电击了。当医生开始评估病人时，有人提到他中枪了。”
While Alan was recovering in the Intensive Care Unit, police handcuffed him to his bed and restricted his family's visits to  just 10 minutes a day, and they couldn't enter the room. They had to look at him through a window. That's because police saw him as a criminal. They charged Alan with two counts of aggravated assault, one for each officer.
在艾伦于重症监护室康复期间，警察将他铐在床上，限制他家人的探视时间每天仅为10分钟，而且他们不能进入房间。他们不得不隔着窗户看他。这是因为警察把他视为罪犯。他们指控艾伦犯有两项加重攻击罪，每一名警官一项。
I couldn't believe it.
我简直不敢相信。
Again, here's Alan.
艾伦再次说道。
I was expecting an apology. I was expecting 100% an apology. And that is not  what happened. And I could not believe it. I couldn't believe it. I don't know if you-- how is it that you have these officers who shoot an unarmed patient in the hospital, and then he is the bad guy, he's the guy who needs to go to jail? And it's jarring. I just don't understand.
我当时在等一个道歉。我百分之百在等一个道歉。但这并没有发生。我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信。我不知道你——怎么会有这样的警察，在医院里枪击一个手无寸铁的病人，然后他反而是坏人，是需要坐牢的那个家伙？这很刺耳。我只是不明白。
Later, when federal investigators asked  Alan about the shooting, he said, quote, "He forgave the police officers. But what he cannot understand is why police officers were in his room, when he was an ill patient trying to get well."
后来，当联邦调查人员就枪击案询问艾伦时，他说，引用，“他原谅了警察。但他无法理解的是，为什么警察会在他的病房里，当时他是一个生病的病人，试图康复。”
So what were armed police doing in a patient's room? This is something a New York Times correspondent, Elisabeth Rosenthal, has been looking into. As I said earlier, the story that you're hearing right now is a collaboration between our radio show and The New York Times . And when Elisabeth Rosenthal heard about Alan Pean, she wondered how common this kind of thing was.
那么武装警察在病房里做什么？这是《纽约时报》记者伊丽莎白·罗森塔尔一直在调查的事情。正如我之前所说的，你现在听到的这个故事是我们广播节目与《纽约时报》合作完成的。当伊丽莎白·罗森塔尔听说艾伦·皮恩时，她想知道这种事情有多普遍。
Elisabeth is also a doctor and has worked  in hospitals, but none that allowed guns. And she just started calling hospitals and looking at the few surveys that exist on this stuff. The one national survey on this subject found that about half of all hospitals now allow guns.
伊丽莎白也是一名医生，在医院工作过，但没有允许枪支的医院。她就开始给医院打电话，查看关于这方面仅有的几项调查。关于这一主题的一项全国调查发现，大约一半的医院现在允许带枪。
And the evidence suggests that that's about doubled in the past three years.
有证据表明，这一数字在过去三年中翻了一番。
Doubled. Lots of hospitals now have police and ex-military doing security with guns. Hospitals aren't required to keep records on how many of their  patients are injured or killed by those guns. But Elisabeth looked for that as well by digging through old police blotters, court documents, news accounts, and surveys, and found over a dozen cases, most of them mentally ill patients.
翻了一番。现在很多医院都有警察和前军人携带枪支进行安保。医院不需要记录有多少病人是被这些枪支伤害或杀害的。但伊丽莎白也通过挖掘旧的警察日志、法庭文件、新闻报道和调查寻找这些信息，发现了十几起案例，大多数是精神病患者。
First, on the very same day that Alan was shot, there was another psychiatric patient who was shot and killed at a hospital in suburban Cleveland. And then, just in January this year, there was another patient with bipolar illness who was shot and paralyzed by security in a Virginia hospital. And then sometimes people die when they're shocked with tasers. So there's two cases, one in Utah and one in Ohio, where patients were actually killed after repeated tasering.
首先，在艾伦被枪击的同一天，另一名精神科病人在克利夫兰郊区的一家医院被枪杀。然后，就在今年1月，另一名患有双相情感障碍的病人在弗吉尼亚州的一家医院被安保人员枪击并瘫痪。有时候人们在被泰瑟枪电击时会死亡。所以有两起案例，一起在犹他州，一起在俄亥俄州，病人在多次泰瑟电击后死亡。
Both were by hospital security. Both were psychiatric patients. Of course, we all would hope that police would know how to deal with people who were mentally ill. They have to do it on the street all the time. But they don't always do it so well.
都是由医院安保执行的。都是精神病患者。当然，我们都希望警察知道如何处理精神病患者。他们在街上总是不得不这样做。但他们并不总是做得那么好。
In December, The Washington Post published the results of a huge, yearlong investigation into police shootings nationwide. They found that last year, officers fatally shot at least 243 people with mental health problems. And in most of those cases, the cops who pulled the trigger hadn't received any training in how to deal with the mentally ill. And their tactics escalated the situation rather than calmed it down.
去年12月，《华盛顿邮报》发布了一项针对全国警察枪击案的巨大、长达一年的调查结果。他们发现去年警察致命枪杀了至少243名有心理健康问题的人。在大多数情况下，扣动扳机的警察没有接受过任何关于如何处理精神病患者的培训。他们的战术升级了局势，而不是使其冷静下来。
So why are hospitals turning to police? Why have the number of guns in hospitals apparently doubled in just three years? Well, for one thing, violence in hospitals has also nearly doubled in that same period. It's up 40% according to statistics gathered by the International Health Care Security and Safety Foundation. Most of that violence is against hospital staff. A study last year by the Occupational Safety and Health Administration revealed that there is more violence in hospitals than any other workplace.
那么为什么医院要求警察介入？为什么医院里的枪支数量在短短三年内明显翻了一番？嗯，一方面，医院内的暴力事件在此期间也几乎翻了一番。根据国际医疗安全与保障基金会收集的统计数据，上升了40%。大多数暴力事件是针对医护人员的。美国职业安全与健康管理局去年的一项研究显示，医院里的暴力事件比任何其他工作场所都要多。
And the way hospitals have responded to this violence, Elisabeth found, is a hodgepodge. One national survey found that half of all hospitals have tasers. They have them partly thanks to an aggressive marketing campaign directed at hospitals by TASER International. In New York's hospital system, which has several of the busiest emergency rooms in the country, security carries no weapons. And lots of hospitals, as I've said, have decided they're comfortable with guns.
伊丽莎白发现，医院应对这种暴力的方式是一盘散沙。一项全国调查发现，半数医院拥有泰瑟枪。他们拥有这些枪支部分要归功于泰瑟国际公司针对医院进行的积极营销活动。在纽约医院系统，拥有全国最繁忙的几个急诊室，安保人员不携带武器。而正如我所说的，许多医院决定他们对枪支感到自在。
Someone said to me-- and I think this is true. It kind of reflects the divide in American society right now about guns, whether they make you feel safer or not.
有人对我说——我认为这是真的。它某种程度上反映了美国社会目前关于枪支的鸿沟，无论它们是否让你感到更安全。
Right. And that just varies around the country, depending on--
对。而这一点在全国范围内各不相同，取决于——
That varies a lot by your background, where you live in the country. Do you feel safer when you see a person with a gun at the door of the emergency room? I think the second issue, then, is if you decide you need weapons in your emergency room or in your hospital, how are the people trained who are using them?
这一点在很大程度上取决于你的背景，你住在国家的什么地方。当你看到急诊室门口有一个带枪的人时，你感到更安全吗？我想第二个问题是，如果你决定在急诊室或医院里需要武器，那么使用武器的人受过什么样的训练？
This may actually be a bigger issue than the guns themselves. Have the people carrying the guns been trained to work in a health care setting? Because it's different. It's not like law enforcement. When there's a patient who's psychotic or acting up from mental illness, like Alan Pean, there are standard techniques that nurses and hospital security use to get control of the situation, non-confrontational ways of speaking to patients, restraints, medicines. Simply warning a patient that you're going to give them a shot can calm them down.
这可能实际上是一个比枪支本身更大的问题。携带枪支的人受过在医疗环境中工作的训练吗？因为它是不同的。它不像执法。当有病人精神错乱或因精神疾病而行为不轨时，比如艾伦·皮恩，护士和医院安保使用标准技术来控制局势，比如非对抗性的方式与病人交谈、限制、药物。仅仅警告病人你要给他们打针就能让他们冷静下来。
And in her research, Elisabeth found some hospitals that taught these techniques to the security officers when they brought in tasers or guns and set clear rules about when to deploy weapons and how armed security would interact with staff and patients. But that definitely wasn't every place.
在她的研究中，伊丽莎白发现一些医院在引入泰瑟枪或枪支时，对安保人员教授了这些技术，并制定了关于何时部署武器以及武装安保人员如何与工作人员和病人互动的明确规则。但这绝对不是每个地方都这样做。
I mean, that's the thing that shocked me. As I called around to different hospitals, there was no pattern to this. It was all over the map. And sometimes there had been a lot of thought put into the process. And sometimes, in fact, there seemed to be very little thought.
我是说，那正是让我震惊的事情。当我打电话给不同的医院时，这没有模式。到处都是。有时人们对这个过程进行了深思熟虑。而有时，事实上，似乎考虑得很少。
When it comes to Alan Pean's case in St. Joseph Medical Center, the federal investigation notes that police officers were supposed to be trained to deescalate situations and restrain confused patients. But there's no evidence that it ever happened.
谈到艾伦·皮恩在圣约瑟夫医学中心的案件，联邦调查指出，警察应该受过降级处理局势和限制困惑病人的训练。但没有证据表明这发生了。
This is quoting from the federal investigation report. Quote, "The facility failed to provide evidence that contracted police officers were trained in dealing with confused, disoriented, and aggressive patients. The facility failed to ensure contract police officers were trained in the use of safe, acceptable health care interventions for confused and aggressive patients. This resulted in the tasering, shooting, and handcuffing of a confused, aggressive patient." End quote.
这是引用联邦调查报告。引用，“该机构未能提供证据证明签约警察受过处理困惑、迷失方向和具有攻击性的病人的培训。该机构未能确保签约警察受过在困惑和具有攻击性的病人身上使用安全、可接受的医疗干预措施的训练。这导致了一名困惑、具有攻击性的病人被泰瑟枪电击、枪击和铐住。”引用结束。
This is actually what was galling to the staffer that I talked to from St. Joseph Medical Center. This person said that these cops were walking into a totally normal situation for the hospital that any trained staff or the regular hospital security could have handled without firearms.
这实际上是让我交谈的那名来自圣约瑟夫医学中心的员工感到气愤的地方。这个人说，这些警察进入的是医院完全正常的情况，任何受过训练的工作人员或常规医院安保都可以不带武器解决。
That's an everyday thing for us. We see that all the time. You see it all day. You see confused, demented people that can be very combative. I mean, hospital staff, we get abused and we're put in more danger than-- or just as much danger as cops on the street.
那对我们来说是每天都在发生的事情。我们经常看到这种情况。你整天都在看。你看到困惑、痴呆的人，他们可能非常有攻击性。我是说，医院员工，我们受到虐待，我们处于比——或者和街上的警察面临一样大的危险。
We don't walk around with guns. We get hit. We get hit by patients all the time. As long as that person doesn't have a weapon to harm someone else, why should you have a weapon? Or why should you use your weapon?
我们没有带着枪走动。我们被打。病人总是打我们。只要那个人没有武器去伤害别人，为什么你应该有武器？或者为什么你应该使用你的武器？
To be clear, this medical staffer thought that it was totally appropriate. They liked it. It made them feel safer that a couple of cops with guns would be in the emergency room in case somebody with a weapon came into the hospital. But sending cops to the room of somebody like Alan Pean? That's totally different.
需要明确的是，这名医护人员认为那是完全适当的。他们喜欢那样。有几个带枪的警察在急诊室以防带武器的人进入医院，这让他们感到更安全。但派警察去艾伦·皮恩那样的人的病房？那完全是另一回事。
First of all, if someone's delusional and two cops walk into the room, it's a normal reaction for that patient that's having delusions, or that psychotic, to react violently. That's how they are. That's what they do.
首先，如果某人有妄想症，两个警察走进房间，对那个有妄想症或精神病的人来说，反应具有暴力倾向是一个正常的反应。他们就是那样。他们就是这么做的。
So you kind of give that space. You stay back. You find out what's going on. You try and talk to them to see if they're safe to approach or not. And that's what-- I'm not sure if that was done or not.
所以你给那个空间。你退后。你找出发生了什么。你尝试跟他们交谈，看看他们是否安全可以靠近。而那正是——我不确定这是否被做了。
To paraphrase an old saying, guns in hospitals don't kill people. Guns in hospitals wielded by people who are not trained to have guns in hospitals kill people.
借用一句古老的话来说，医院里的枪支不会杀人。在医院里由没有受过在医院使用枪支训练的人挥舞枪支才会杀人。
So better training of the officers in Alan Pean's case might have prevented the shooting. But in this particular case, there was something else that could have stopped this from happening, something simple. Alan could have been given a psychiatric evaluation.
所以对艾伦·皮恩案件中的警察进行更好的训练可能阻止了枪击。但在这种特定情况下，还有别的事情可能阻止这件事发生，很简单的事情。艾伦本可以接受精神病评估。
Remember, the ER staff noted Alan's erratic mental state in his chart but didn't get him evaluated. And Alan's father asked for a psych evaluation, but he was ignored. The St. Joseph staffer that I talked to said it's hard to understand why.
记住，急诊室工作人员在图表中记录了艾伦不稳定的精神状态，但没有让他接受评估。艾伦的父亲要求进行心理评估，但他被无视了。我交谈的那名圣约瑟夫员工说很难理解为什么。
I hate to say it because we never want to talk bad about anyone that we work with-- and I wasn't there, but if that was said to a medical professional, then their wishes should have been complied with immediately. That's the protocol. That's what's supposed to happen.
我不喜欢这么说，因为我们永远不想说我们一起工作的任何人的坏话——我当时不在场，但如果那是对医疗专业人员说的，那么他们的意愿就应该立即得到满足。那是规程。那是应该发生的事。
And is it true that if he had been diagnosed as a psych patient, he would have been in a psych ward where no guns are allowed?
是真的吗，如果他被诊断为精神病病人，他会被安置在精神病房，那里不允许带枪？
Correct.
正确。
So that would've prevented this whole thing?
所以那本会阻止整件事？
Correct.
正确。
You don't want guns in psychiatry wards for common sense reasons. It's too dangerous. You don't want a patient to grab the gun. And seeing firearms might agitate certain patients.
出于常识，你不希望精神病房里有枪。太危险了。你不希望病人抢枪。而且看到枪支可能会激怒某些病人。
Because of that, almost universally guns are banned from state mental hospitals in the United States. When officers enter those facilities, they check their guns at the door. Possibly the one exception is Texas, where Alan was shot, where just last month on January 1, four months after Alan's shooting, it became legal to carry licensed firearms in state-run psychiatric hospitals.
正因为如此，美国几乎普遍禁止在州立精神病院携带枪支。当警察进入这些设施时，他们会在门口检查枪支。可能的一个例外是德克萨斯州，即艾伦被枪击的地方，就在上个月的1月1日，即艾伦枪击案发生四个月后，在州立精神病院携带合法枪支变得合法了。
When the Pean family filed a complaint against the hospital with the federal government, specifically the Centers for Medicare and Medicaid Services, or CMS, CMS felt the shooting raised serious enough questions about St. Joseph Medical Center that they had investigators at the hospital within five days of the shooting and publicly raised the possibility that St. Joseph might lose its federal funding. When the investigators interviewed St. Joseph's Chief Executive Officer Mark Bernard about the incident, he told them that he stood by the officers.
当皮恩一家向联邦政府，特别是医疗保险和医疗补助服务中心，即CMS，投诉该医院时，CMS认为枪击事件引发了关于圣约瑟夫医学中心的足够严重的问题，以至于他们在枪击事件发生后的五天内就在医院有了调查人员，并公开提出了圣约瑟夫可能会失去联邦资金的可能性。当调查人员采访圣约瑟夫的首席执行官马克·伯纳德关于此事时，他告诉他们，他支持这些警察。
This from the report, he said, quote, that "the minute the patient hit the uniformed police officer, it became a criminal offense, and the officers went into police mode and were justified in the actions they took to protect themselves." When asked what other interventions could have been used by the security staff, the CEO said, quote, "if it should happen today, they would not have done anything different."
来自报告，他说，引用，病人击中身穿制服的警察的那一刻，这就变成了刑事犯罪，警察进入了警察模式，他们为保护自己所采取的行动是合理的。当被问到安保人员可以使用什么其他干预措施时，首席执行官说，引用，“如果今天发生同样的事情，他们不会做任何不同的处理。”
I wondered if the CEO still felt that way, given the evidence in the federal report that police officers may not have been properly trained to deal with a patient like Alan Pean and that hospital staff failed to do a psychiatric evaluation. The hospital referred this and all of our questions to an outside crisis manager they work with named Rhonda Barnat. I was told that CEO Mark Bernard declined to answer that question.
我不知道鉴于联邦报告中警察可能没有受过妥善训练来处理像艾伦·皮恩这样的病人，且医院工作人员未能进行精神病评估的证据，首席执行官是否仍然有这种感觉。医院将这个问题以及我们所有的提问交给了他们合作的一位外部危机经理，名字叫朗达·巴纳特。我被告知首席执行官马克·伯纳德拒绝回答这个问题。
I ran CEO Mark Bernard's statement, quote, "If it should happen today, they would not have done anything different," by Alan's father. Remember, as a physician and familiar with hospitals and how they work, his response is that of a doctor and a father.
我把首席执行官马克·伯纳德的声明，引用，“如果今天发生同样的事情，他们不会做任何不同的处理，”告诉了艾伦的父亲。记住，作为一名医生，熟悉医院及其运作方式，他的回应是一位医生和一位父亲的回应。
That's crazy. That's totally crazy. Can you believe that? So he didn't see anything wrong. He said that was normal procedure. I mean, can you believe a CEO saying that? That's terrible. I don't understand it. So that would be standard procedure for a patient who's sick, instead of sending their doctor, send police officers and shoot them. That's totally absurd.
那太疯狂了。那完全疯狂。你能相信吗？所以他没觉得有什么不对。他说那是标准程序。我是说，你能相信首席执行官这么说吗？那太可怕了。我不明白。所以这就是对待生病病人的标准程序，不派医生，却派警察并射杀他们。这完全荒谬。
We sent what Alan's dad said to the hospital's crisis manager to give CEO Mark Bernard a chance to respond, along with a long list of other questions. In reply, the hospital issued this statement, which it said came from CEO Mark Bernard. Quote, "In the wake of this sad event, we are reviewing our practices and procedures as we continue to provide the best possible care to those we serve."
我们把艾伦父亲所说的发送给了医院的危机经理，给首席执行官马克·伯纳德一个回应的机会，以及一份长长的其他提问清单。作为回复，医院发表了这份声明，称其来自首席执行官马克·伯纳德。引用，“在这场悲惨事件之后，我们正在审查我们的实践和程序，因为我们继续为我们服务的人提供尽可能最好的护理。”
Change is happening at St. Joseph. According to the report by federal investigators, St. Joseph is now limited where police officers can go in the hospital to peripheral areas. They can't go to patients' rooms unless staff has tried everything else to calm a situation. St. Joseph also has to do crisis prevention training with staff and police. They have 17 months to get their act together, or they lose their federal funding.
圣约瑟夫正在发生变化。根据联邦调查人员的报告，圣约瑟夫现在限制了警察可以在医院里去的地方，只能去外围区域。除非工作人员已经尝试了其他所有方法来使局势冷静下来，否则他们不能去病房。圣约瑟夫还必须对工作人员和警察进行危机预防培训。他们有17个月的时间来纠正错误，否则他们将失去联邦资金。
OK. So basically, you drove yourself to a hospital. And when you're at the hospital, you said explicitly, you're having a manic episode. You're unarmed. And you end up shot.
好的。所以基本上，你自己开车去了医院。当你在医院时，你明确说，你正在经历躁狂发作。你手无寸铁。最后你却中枪了。
Yep. Correct.
是的。没错。
OK. I don't even know what my question is. I just want to say, that seems bad.
好的。我甚至不知道我的问题是什么。我只是想说，那看起来很糟糕。
On a whole bunch of levels. And that opened my eyes in a way that I sort of never want it to.
在很多层面上。那让我大开眼界，以一种我不希望的方式。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Well, I'm black.
嗯，我是黑人。
Because you don't think this would have happened if you were white?
因为你不认为如果你是白人这会发生？
No, I don't.
不，我不认为。
Yeah.
是的。
That the only reason this guy was able to look at me and decide that, hey, he needs to be shot in the chest. I think they just-- another black guy acting crazy. Angry black guy.
那个人能够看着我并决定，嘿，他需要被射中胸部，唯一的原因就是我是黑人。我想他们只是——又一个发疯的黑人。愤怒的黑人。
In the immediate wake of the shooting, Alan's father says that one of the questions that police asked him over and over was, did Alan have a criminal record? Alan told me that, of course, he's seen all the news stories about young black men being shot by police.
在枪击事件发生后，艾伦的父亲说警察反复问他的一个问题是，艾伦有犯罪记录吗？艾伦告诉我，当然，他看过所有关于年轻黑人被警察枪杀的新闻报道。
I would think outrage. It's an outrage. It's a complete outrage. But I would never think that it would happen to me. I'm privileged, right? I acknowledge that. I acknowledge I'm privileged.
我会认为是愤慨。这是愤怒。这是完全的愤怒。但我从未想过这会发生在我身上。我有特权，对吧？我承认这一点。我承认我有特权。
This is a family of doctors, a family with money. That car that he crashed into the hospital was a 2010 Lexus.
这是一个医生家庭，一个有钱的家庭。他撞进医院的那辆车是2010年的雷克萨斯。
And it's interesting. Of the four black men in the family, three of them thought that they were living a life where they would never have this kind of run-in with a cop. One of Alan's closest friends is a cop. His dad is friends with cops. Only Christian, the oldest son, thought it could happen to him. In fact, when his father texted him the day of the shooting to say that something had happened-- Alan was in the ICU, they didn't know what happened yet-- Christian's first text back was, wait, what? What? Did they shoot him?
很有趣。在家庭里的四名黑人男性中，三个人认为他们过着永远不会与警察发生这种冲突的生活。艾伦最亲密的朋友之一就是警察。他父亲和警察是朋友。只有克里斯蒂安，最大的儿子，认为这可能发生在他身上。事实上，当他父亲在枪击那天给他发短信说发生了什么事——艾伦在重症监护室，他们还不知道发生了什么——克里斯蒂安回的第一条短信是，等等，什么？什么？他们枪击他了吗？
Alan Pean nearly died. The bullet hit him squarely in the chest. It missed his aorta by millimeters. He lost a third of the blood in his body.
艾伦·皮恩差点死了。子弹直中他的胸部。距离主动脉只有几毫米。他失去了身体三分之一的血液。
I can't believe that I'm even here, walking around, standing. And I don't know why he would shoot me in the chest unless he was trying to kill me. That's a kill shot, so that's-- I don't think too much about it. I try not to, I think, actually, honestly.
我简直不敢相信我还在这里，走来走去，站着。而且我不知道他为什么要射中我的胸部，除非他想杀我。那是致命一枪，所以那是——我对此想得不多。我想我尽量不去想，实际上，老实说。
Because it just freaked you out?
因为那吓到你了？
It does.
确实。
Yeah.
是的。
And I really can't handle it sometimes. Well, I can take it. I heard you say it like that. It's just, I still think I'm in shock, that I don't know how to handle it. I don't know how to handle it.
而且有时我真的无法处理。好吧，我能承受。我听到你这么说。只是，我觉得我仍然处于震惊中，我不懂得怎么去处理它。我不懂得怎么去处理它。
Well, yeah. That day in August, Alan had a delusion that people were out to kill him, that if he walked out of his apartment, he'd be shot. There were assassins after him. He was going to get shot. And then, he was shot. This literally crazy thought came true. How do you make sense of that?
嗯，是的。八月的那一天，艾伦有一种妄想，认为人们想杀他，如果他走出公寓，他会被枪杀。有杀手在追他。他会中枪。然后，他确实中枪了。这个完全疯狂的想法成真了。你怎么去理解这一点？
The New York Times ' version of this story is online at their website. It's great, with great photos, at nytimes.com/hospital. Since we first aired this story in 2016, the assault charges against Alan Pean were dismissed by a grand jury. Another grand jury looked into the behavior of the two officers involved in this shooting and did not indict them. The Texas State Legislature is currently considering a new bill that would allow state-run psychiatric hospitals to ban guns again.
《纽约时报》关于这个故事的版本在他们的网站上。很棒，配有很棒的照片，在nytimes.com/hospital。自从我们在2016年首次播出这个故事以来，对艾伦·皮恩的攻击指控被大陪审团驳回了。另一个大陪审团调查了参与这次枪击案的两名警察的行为，并没有起诉他们。德克萨斯州立法机构目前正在考虑一项新法案，将再次允许州立精神病院禁止枪支。
Coming up, consciously telling yourself things that you know are not true as a way to use your mind and its power. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，有意识地告诉自己一些你知道不真实的事情，作为一种利用你的大脑及其力量的方式。一分钟后，从芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "My Damn Mind."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“我该死的大脑”。
Our first act was about somebody whose mind was sending him jumping off of balconies. And now, in this part of our show, we're turning to a very different story-- still about a man and his brain and the awesome and confounding power of one's own mind. In this case, though, it is about a man harnessing that power for a constructive purpose of his own. This is Act Two of our show. Act Two, "Don't Need to Know Basis."
我们的第一幕是关于某人的大脑让他从阳台上跳下来。现在，在节目的这一部分，我们转向一个截然不同的故事——仍然是关于一个男人和他的大脑，以及他自身大脑那种令人敬畏和困惑的力量。不过在这种情况下，它是关于一个人为了自己建设性的目的利用那种力量。这是我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，“不需要知道的依据”。
The man in this story is Michael Kinsley-- writer, editor, known for, among other things, starting the online magazine Slate and for being just a very sharp, funny observer of American politics and human nature generally, including his own nature. He is a human. Nancy Updike talked to him.
这个故事中的男人是迈克尔·金斯利——作家、编辑，以创办在线杂志《Slate》以及作为美国政治和人类本性，包括他自己本性，非常敏锐、有趣的观察者而闻名。他是一个人。南希·厄普代克采访了他。
Michael Kinsley wrote an essay years ago-- it was funny, naturally-- in which he announced that he had Parkinson's Disease. The essay was called "In Defense of Denial," because what he was really announcing was that he had already had Parkinson's for the previous eight years. In that time, he said, the way he had chosen to use his mind, his deliberate strategy for dealing with Parkinson's, had been denial. And he was not writing to confess or apologize or to vow not to engage in denial in the future. He was talking about the benefits of self-deception and secrecy.
迈克尔·金斯利多年前写过一篇文章——自然很有趣——在文章中他宣布自己患有帕金森病。文章标题是“为否认辩护”，因为他真正宣布的是，他在此前的八年里就已经患有帕金森病了。他说，在那段时间里，他选择使用大脑的方式，他应对帕金森病的刻意策略，一直是否认。他不是为了忏悔或道歉，或者发誓未来不再进行否认而写作。他谈论的是自我欺骗和保密的益处。
His argument was, when it comes to serious illness, like with all terrible things that happen to us, sure, yes, the goal is to get to acceptance-- eventually, if you can. But acceptance is not a strategy, he said. It's not something you can just do. He said, really, there are only two strategies, denial or confrontation.
他的论点是，当涉及到严重的疾病时，就像发生在我们身上所有的可怕事情一样，当然，是的，目标是最终实现接受——如果你能的话。但他说是说接受不是一种策略。这不是你可以简单做到的。他说，实际上，只有两种策略，否认或对抗。
Confrontation, it's the strategy that everything in our culture pushes you toward, fighting it all the way. And also joining the community of sufferers of whatever, making it your life. Who are you? I'm someone with Parkinson's. And I'm going off to my support group.
对抗，这是我们文化中一切都推动你走向的策略，一直与之斗争。而且还要加入无论什么的受害者社区，将其作为你的生活。你是谁？我是一个患有帕金森病的人。我正要去参加我的互助小组。
Right. They really engage.
对。他们确实很投入。
Yes. Michael J. Fox is an example, and a thoroughly admirable example of how to react. He's made it his cause, both his public cause and his personal cause. And that's great. But I just decided, that is not for me.
是的。迈克尔·J·福克斯是一个例子，一个彻底令人钦佩的关于如何应对的例子。他将其作为自己的事业，既是公共事业也是个人事业。那很好。但我只是决定，那不适合我。
You went with denial.
你选择了否认。
Denial, which is the opposite. You don't think about it. You don't get involved. You don't learn everything you can about it. You try to live your life and spend your time outside of that world. And in many ways, this was a cowardly choice. But it was the choice I made.
否认，这是相反的。你不去想它。你不参与其中。你不去尽可能多地了解它。你试图过你的生活，把时间花在那个世界之外。在很多方面，这是一个懦弱的选择。但这是我做出的选择。
I really appreciate a person who's prepared to use every mental trick in dealing with sickness. Mike's essay spoke to me. I have experienced the clear benefits of denial. I know what it's like to choose that option.
我真的很欣赏一个准备好在处理疾病时使用每一个心理技巧的人。迈克的话触动了我。我已经体验到了否认的明显好处。我知道选择那个选项是什么感觉。
I had a tumor in my abdomen three years ago-- cancer. In the week before the surgery, denial-- carefully executed not thinking-- was my only goal. I wasn't graceful or even logical about it. For some reason, my denial involved making several trips to the drugstore, Duane Reade, to buy dental floss, and yet more dental floss. Not sure why floss. Mike suggested maybe I was stockpiling a message to myself. You will live to floss long into the future.
三年前我的腹部有一个肿瘤——癌症。在手术前的一周，否认——精心执行的不去想——是我唯一的目标。我对此既不优雅也不合逻辑。出于某种原因，我的否认涉及多次去药店，Duane Reade，去买牙线，以及更多更多的牙线。不确定为什么牙线。迈克建议也许我是在囤积一个留给自己的信息。你将活得很久，并一直使用牙线。
When he chose denial, Mike did feel bad about deceiving other people, not just the general public but also people he knew. And he said he tried not to lie outright. But denial was very good to him. It gave him eight years of privacy, eight years of relative normalcy. Nothing else could have done that. And he saw another benefit.
当他选择否认时，迈克确实对欺骗其他人感到难过，不仅是大众，还有他认识的人。他说他尽量不直接撒谎。但否认对他非常好。它给了他八年的隐私，八年的相对正常。没有其他东西能做到这一点。他又看到了另一个好处。
If you're lucky, you have good friends and close relatives who are going to help you get through it. But the best person in the world's sympathy is going to be limited. So you do think, well, do I want to use that up?
如果你幸运的话，你有好朋友和近亲会帮助你度过难关。但世界上最好的人的同情心也是有限的。所以你确实会想，好吧，我想要用完它吗？
Maybe that's a crazy way to look at it. But I thought, I'm going to need their sympathy in years to come. And I don't especially need it now.
也许那是一种疯狂的看法。但我想，在未来的岁月里我将需要他们的同情。而我现在并不特别需要它。
As Mike's symptoms progressed, bit by bit, some tremors, some stiffness, he told more people, bit by bit. And he ignored each person's advice in turn because every person was saying the same thing-- no more denial. The upshot was that Mike continued not reading up on Parkinson's, continued trying to know as little as possible, while his friends were reading up. Thanks to a couple of them, he ended up at the Cleveland Clinic to get brain surgery, basically because his friends had been badgering him to go there and see a doctor who was surgically placing electrodes in the brains of people with Parkinson's to help slow down the progress of the disease's physical symptoms.
随着迈克的症状逐渐加重，一些颤抖，一些僵硬，他告诉了更多人，一点一点。他反过来忽略了每个人的建议，因为每个人都在说同样的话——不要再否认了。结果是迈克继续不去阅读关于帕金森病的东西，继续试图知道得越少越好，而他的朋友们正在阅读。多亏了其中几个，他最终去了克利夫兰诊所接受脑部手术，基本上是因为他的朋友一直缠着他去那里看一位医生，那位医生正在手术地将电极植入帕金森病人的大脑中，以帮助减缓疾病的物理症状进程。
Well, it was sort of a slippery slope. They said, why don't you just go and let him examine you and see if you're suitable for it.
嗯，那是一个滑坡。他们说，你为什么不去让他检查一下，看看你是否适合它。
It's like a blind date. Maybe just go meet her. She's nice.
就像相亲。也许只是去见见她。她很好。
Yeah. Yes. Well, I did. And they wanted to make sure you were up for this. And after I had been to Cleveland two or three times, they suddenly said, well, how about July 12? I'm making up the date. But they--
是的。是的。嗯，我去了。他们想确保你准备好做这个。在我去过克利夫兰两三次后，他们突然说，7月12日怎么样？我编造了这个日期。但他们——
Wow. They got very specific all of a sudden.
哇。他们突然变得非常具体。
Yeah. And I didn't think about it nearly as long as I should have. There is a controversy about which particular spot in the brain you should go to. And different surgeons do different spots. But that's a perfect example of something I didn't research but that many people would and do. But I said, OK. And the next thing I knew, I was in Cleveland.
是的。我考虑的时间远没有我应该考虑的那么长。关于你应该去大脑中的哪个特定点存在争议。不同的外科医生做不同的点。但那是一个我没有研究但许多人会研究并且确实研究过的东西的完美例子。但我说，好的。我还没反应过来，我就在克利夫兰了。
And were you nervous?
你紧张吗？
Yeah. I mean, I'm not that good at denial that I wouldn't be nervous about brain surgery. So they just-- they said we're just going to make a little hole. And they said it's just dime-sized. And that took me back, because I think of a dime-sized hole as being pretty big.
是的。我是说，我不擅长否认到连脑部手术都不会紧张。所以他们只是——他们说我们只是要挖一个小洞。他们说那只有一角硬币大小。那让我退缩了，因为我认为一角硬币大小的洞相当大。
Large. For them it's small. For you, it's big. Because it's your brain.
大。对他们来说是小的。对你来说，很大。因为那是你的大脑。
Yeah. But I thought, well, this is how they do it.
是的。但我心想，嗯，这就是他们的做法。
OK. And they screw your head to the table so it won't move while the surgery is happening right? Even though it's general anesthesia, it's not local or anything.
好的。他们把你的头拧在桌子上，这样在手术发生时它就不会动，对吧？尽管是全身麻醉，不是局部麻醉什么的。
No. No, it's not general anesthesia.
不。不，不是全身麻醉。
You were awake?
你是清醒的？
For most of the time.
大部分时间。
Oh, my god.
哦，我的天。
Because they had to-- well, it's like you're down in the basement trying to replace a fuse. And someone has to go upstairs to see if the light comes on. And so that was me.
因为他们必须——嗯，就像你在地下室试图更换保险丝。必须有人上楼看看灯是否亮了。所以那个人是我。
Right. You were the test about whether they were getting it right.
对。你是关于他们是否做得对的测试。
Yeah. And it was quite weird. They could press a button or something, and my hand would start to wave.
是的。而且非常奇怪。他们可以按一个按钮什么的，我的手就会开始挥动。
The surgery did what it was supposed to. It slowed the progress of the physical symptoms which then allowed Mike to continue his project of exercising however much denial he possibly could at every stage.
手术做了它应该做的事。它减缓了物理症状的进展，然后允许迈克继续他试图在每一个阶段都尽可能多地行使否认的项目。
Parkinson's isn't usually fatal. Or, as Mike has cheerfully written over the years, Parkinson's gives you a decent chance for something else to get you first. But Parkinson's does get worse over time.
帕金森病通常不是致命的。或者，正如迈克多年来愉快地写道，帕金森病给你一个体面的机会让别的东西先夺走你。但帕金森病确实会随着时间推移而恶化。
And maybe even more galling, Parkinson's is not just one thing. Eight years after the brain surgery, Mike wrote another essay about Parkinson's in The New Yorker . It's called "Have You Lost Your Mind?" Look it up if you haven't read it. It's great. It's about the research, more and more of it over the last couple of decades, indicating that Parkinson's can include cognitive symptoms. It can affect your thinking.
也许更让人恼火的是，帕金森病不仅仅是一件事。脑部手术八年后，迈克在《纽约客》上写了另一篇关于帕金森病的文章。标题是“你失去理智了吗？”如果你还没读过，去看看。很棒。它是关于过去几十年来越来越多的研究，表明帕金森病可能包括认知症状。它会影响你的思维。
A doctor once said to you when you asked him-- I think it was a him-- when you asked him about the cognitive issues associated with Parkinson's, he said, well, you may lose your edge.
一位医生曾经在你问他时对你说——我想是位他——当你问他关于与帕金森病相关的认知问题时，他说，嗯，你可能会失去优势。
Yes. That was the most terrifying moment, I think, in the whole process. I mean, I make my living off of my edge. And also, it's part of my sense of who I am.
是的。那是我认为整个过程中最可怕的时刻。我是说，我靠我的优势为生。而且这也是我对自己是谁的感知的一部分。
He thought he was sort of soft-pedaling something, saying, oh, you might lose your edge, as though you're still an intact thing with just a slightly softer edge. And meanwhile, for you, you were thinking, but I am my edge. My edge is me. I'm not a thing with an edge. The edge is-- that's me. That's what feels like me.
他以为他是在某种程度上软化了什么，说，哦，你可能会失去优势，就好像你仍然是一个完整的东西，只是优势稍微软化了一点。而同时，对你来说，你在想，但我就是我的优势。我的优势就是我。我不是一个有优势的东西。优势是——那就是我。那才是让我感觉是我自己的东西。
Yeah, that's exactly it. But let me say to anyone who cares who's listening that I have not lost my mind.
是的，正是那样。但让我对任何正在倾听并在意的人说，我没有失去理智。
Mike says the rallying cry for his generation is death before dementia, only after a very long life, of course. He wrote in his New Yorker essay that the kind of thing you'd want people to say about you, looking back, would be something like, "he was 102 years old when he was accidentally shot by a neighbor and still sharp as a tack."
迈克说他这一代人的战斗口号是痴呆前死亡，当然是在非常长寿之后。他在《纽约客》文章中写道，你会想要人们对你评价的那种事情，回顾过去，会是像这样的，“他102岁时被邻居意外枪杀，依然思维敏捷。”
Parkinson's is different from Alzheimer's. The cognitive issues vary a lot from person to person, and they're still being researched. But dementia is one possibility. And a big reason we know that is because other people with Parkinson's-- the confronters, not the deniers-- are talking about it.
帕金森病与阿尔茨海默病不同。认知问题因人而异，而且仍在研究中。但痴呆是一种可能性。我们知道这一点的一个重要原因是因为其他帕金森病人——那些对抗者，而不是否认者——正在谈论它。
Most of our information about cognitive problems comes from the patient, him or herself. And I'm thinking, are these people out of their minds?
我们关于认知问题的大部分信息来自病人他自己。我在想，这些人失去理智了吗？
You want to send a mass email to everybody with Parkinson's just saying, can we all just not talk about this? Why are we talking about this?
你想给每个患有帕金森病的人发一封群邮件，只是说，我们能都不谈论这个吗？为什么我们在谈论这个？
Yes. Well, when I hear people talking about this, I think, shut up. Shut up.
是的。嗯，当我听到人们谈论这个时，我想，闭嘴。闭嘴。
You actually think "shut up" at them?
你实际上在想“闭嘴”对他们说？
Yeah. It doesn't work. I switch back into denial when it comes to the cognitive thing. And yet here I am, discussing it on a national radio show, so obviously my motives are mixed.
是的。没用。当涉及到认知问题时，我切换回否认状态。然而我却在这里，在全国电台节目中讨论它，所以显然我的动机是混合的。
Do you not want to talk about it?
你不想谈论它吗？
Well, we have nothing else to talk about, Nancy.
嗯，我们没别的话可谈了，南希。
I'm sure we could find something.
我确信我们能找到什么。
Yes, well, we've got the New Hampshire primary.
是的，嗯，我们有新罕布什尔州初选。
Yes, yes. Did you watch the Super Bowl?
是的，是的。你看超级碗了吗？
No.
没有。
No? Beyonce? Anything?
没有？碧昂丝？什么东西？
Eh.
呃。
No?
没有？
No. What's she done?
没有。她做了什么？
Nancy Updike is one of the producers of our program. Michael Kinsley is a contributing columnist for Vanity Fair and The Washington Post . His latest book is Old Age: A Beginner's Guide .
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的制作人之一。迈克尔·金斯利是《名利场》和《华盛顿邮报》的特约专栏作家。他最新的书是《老年：初学者指南》。
[MUSIC - "FORMATION" BY BEYONCE]
[音乐 - 碧昂丝的“FORMATION”]
Our program was produced today by Chana Jofee-Walt, with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our editor is Joel Lovell. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Production help from Lyra Smith. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our business operations manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for our show. Kimberly Henderson is our office coordinator. Research help today from Christopher Swetala and Benjamin Anastas. Music help today from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由Chana Jofee-Walt制作，Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。我们的资深制作人是Brian Reed。我们的编辑是Joel Lovell。Julie Snyder是我们的编辑顾问。我们的技术总监是Matt Tierney。Lyra Smith提供制作帮助。Seth Lind是我们的运营总监。Emily Condon是我们的制作经理。Elise Bergerson是我们的业务运营经理。Elna Baker为我们的节目寻找故事。Kimberly Henderson是我们的办公室协调员。Christopher Swetala和Benjamin Anastas今天提供研究帮助。Damien Graef和Rob Geddis今天提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, how do I get through this program every week? Let me tell you, I just come in to the studio, I look up at the photo of Torey Malatia that is here in the radio studio, and I can hear his voice in my head, saying--
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交流电台提供给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，Torey Malatia先生。你知道，我每周怎么度过这个节目？让我告诉你，我只是走进录音室，抬头看一眼在广播室里的Torey Malatia的照片，我能在脑海里听到他的声音，说——
Just remember your training. You trained for this.
记住你的训练。你为此训练过。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WHERE IS MY MIND" BY VANILLA FUDGE]
[音乐 - 香草软糖乐队的“WHERE IS MY MIND”]